all right welcome everybody yeah after
the introduction hopefully you walk away
and learn something in this talk so
quantum computing if you read whatever
is in the press you either think we are
completely doomed and you know the
Internet's gonna end or nothing's gonna
happen because they will never exist so
I thought I won't explore this topic a
little bit more from an algorithmic
point of view and really see where we
are not so much on the hype but more
really what are the algorithms that we
talk about right now so um I started
various companies in the security space
you know starting 2002 which makes me
feel slightly out right now
but first I'm speaking at Def Con very
happy about this you know long term
attendee but never spoke you so let's
get right into this so when you talk
about cryptography we mainly you know
look into two different types of
cryptography once it's a symmetric
crypto system which is a symmetric
shared key you know kind of like AES for
example both sides encrypt and talk to
each other with the same key and with
isometric crypto systems which use
public key infrastructure where
basically I use a public key to encrypt
a message and a private key to decrypt
it there's various forms of this
obviously for these digital signatures
as well and in in this realm
virtually every crypto system right now
that is deployed anywhere is what we
call computationally secure that is
secure in the sense that there are known
algorithms that can break them but all
of the algorithms I think break them are
not easy to do in the sense that you
know if I want to break and you know 20
48 hours I key with a normal computer
takes me a couple of trillion years
which means I'm secure even though
there's some known algorithms that can
break them there are information
theoretic algorithms out there most
notably an algorithm called a one-time
pad or Wernham ciphers but they're
really tricky and not really practically
usable for example its one-time pad you
do need to use the same amount of keys
as you want a transmitter if you want to
transmit a one megabyte file you need to
have a one megabyte key
before every bite you need a different
for everybody you need a one by T so you
would have to manage massive amount of
key material which is not really
practically but I mean they do exist but
outside of this virtually every crypto
system is just a computationally secure
and when you look at this quantum realm
and are going to quite some detail about
this for those two different types of
algorithms it is much more interesting
to look at the asymmetric part of the of
the crypto systems because in a
symmetric part there is a quantum
algorithm as well called growver which
basically looks into a provides a
quadratic speed up to the classical
version basically in the classical world
if I want to look for this shared key I
need to basically brute-force every
different combination which obviously
takes forever I get a squared root up
squared speed up in the quantum version
which is a fantastic speed up you know
if I can speed up a hundred 50 trillion
years is you know a lot of years but it
still obviously hundred fifty trillion
years to break it so that's not really
too interesting so we want to focus here
on the isometric path where the speed
ups at quantum computers can provide are
massive and we want to go to quite some
detail why their speed-up is so big as
it is and how they work so let's revisit
it just a little bit of how RSI
encryption works and it's really just a
basic introduction so we can use them to
understand how the quantum versions of
these algorithm works basically I choose
two prime numbers P and Q and with those
I just multiply them get the number n
now with the number n I can calculate
this lambda in function which is a
Carmichael function which is just the
function I can easily calculate this and
once I have this I just choose another
parameter e which is smaller than the
lambda n value and then this n together
with the number E is my public key I can
give this to everybody out there who I
want to choose to do the isometric
encryption and I basically retain my
private key which is this number D here
which is just the
modular inverse of the number E which is
the public key obviously mod lambda n is
always mod lambda n kind of in this
scenario which is the private key that I
retain and with this private key now
with this scenario I can now look into
hi I cannot crypt something and send
something from Alice to Bob and as
everybody knows with isometric
encryption I can not only encrypt
something that is smaller than my key so
if I have a 2 for 2048 bit key I can
only encrypt something that is smaller
than 2048 so I need to pair my plaintext
into a number n so I turn this Big M
into a small number M there's various
way for this device for this I don't go
into too much detail but this is where
the padding scheme comes in and then I
basically end up with this number small
m and my ciphertext my encrypted
versions really I just take this number
m ^ e mod n and that's basically my
ciphertext and this is what I encrypt
with the public key and I can now send
this number C to to pop or receive this
and if you have the private key you can
easily decrypt this as well on the other
side and you can easily see how this
works it is really very straightforward
if someone has the C and the ciphertext
and the D the private key by definition
C is M ^ e so you see but the definition
of D was that is actually the inverse of
e so this e ^ d just equals out so I end
up with M mod n so if I have the private
key I can easily recover I'm the small M
and obviously by just reversing the
padding scheme I have now my my message
again so this is basically how our si
encryption works into some detail so my
tasks now I do have a public key because
that's public everybody knows what the
public keys how do I turn this into a
private key now from the Davis
from the definitions it's really pretty
straightforward and simple
I need to find those prime numbers that
make up this number n the number n is
known as part of the public key and if I
can do this
I can easily calculate lambda n which is
really just the least common multiplier
of lambda P n lambda Q and from that I
can easily derive the private key D and
I'm done so all I need to do to
basically go from a public key to
private key is to find those two prime
factors P and Q that I chose in the very
beginning when I set up my key and then
I have everything I need to do to
basically derive a private key from a
public key while that sounds pretty easy
and straightforward actually to do this
and to factor this number n into the two
prime parts p and q is it's really
really hard and all of the classically
known algorithms are all from
exponential complexity which means
they're really really hard to solve even
you know the gfs algorithm is slightly
sub-exponential but still massive in
scale so that gives you those assurance
that if you have if you use any of the
isometric algorithms people would need
trillions of years to decrypt them so
they're fairly secure for generations to
come but in 1994 a guy called Peter Shaw
he was a theoretical physicist came up
with this algorithm if we were to use
quantum computers obviously in 1994
there was all just a theory quantum
computers didn't exist and they hardly
existed I but but the theory says he
came up with an algorithm of how to
factor those numbers in just polynomial
time and it just polynomial time really
is a difference that is there is almost
incomprehensible because it really means
instead of taking a trillion years on a
classic computer with a trillion
operations per second let's suppose have
a quantum computer which just has a
million operations per second I can
actually do the same thing in just 10
seconds so the difference between
exponential complexity and polynomial
complexity is just out of this world and
that obviously
we could run this algorithm would pose a
big threat to basically the whole crypto
systems editors as it is deployed
because the base of this whether it is
you know for RSI or elliptic curves or
for digital signatures ECDSA which is
using Bitcoin or for a key exchange like
diffie-hellman which is mainly used in
everywhere you go on ssl/tls exchanges
so the base foundation of this is used
virtually everywhere
in today's internet so that would be a
big threat so let's explore a little bit
how Peter Shaw could came up with his
algorithms what is actually needed and
how they work in in reality so now we
need to do a little bit of an
introduction into quantum computing and
it gets only as deep as I thought we
need to go to understand how short
algorithm works and what we need to
understand so hopefully it's not it's
not too bad so basically there are two
big types of quantum computers that we
look at right now one is called gate
based quantum computers that's a big
chunk what everybody's working on all
the big guys IBM Intel Microsoft Alibaba
they're all working on guide biased
quantum computing which is called
universal quantum computing because I
can solve virtually any problem similar
to a classical computing on this
computer there's in a different computer
called quantum Manila's or adiabatic
quantum computing which is what's the
first quantum computer that was
available was from dear wife auntie
wife's computer this adiabatic quantum
computer is not a channel quantum
computer you cannot solve every problem
on this quantum computer it is very
specialized to only solve a particular
optimization problem so it's very much
you can look at this basically as a
physical system and physical systems
tend to always end up in the lowest
energy state which we call the ground
side of this physical system so if I can
now define a function that I want to
solve and I basically define those
function in a way that the lowest energy
state is basically the same as
solution to this optimization problem I
can use this physical system to solve
the problem that I have because I know
the physical system will end up in the
lowest energy sight in the ground sight
and I know then this also 10 this also
represents in the state where my
optimization problem reached the lowest
point and that's a really cool I'm a
theorem which actually guarantees to me
that I end up in the lowest state that
there is you can really think of this as
kind of like mountains and valleys and
you can end up in a valley that is just
halfway through and you're not really in
the lowest tide but there's a theorem we
are going to explore it's a limit which
guarantees which gives me why how can
really be it the lowest state so I can
solve ok I can find the optimal solution
to the optimization problem but it's
really just solving optimization
problems the guide based quantum
computing is really a general quantum
general computing architecture where you
start with an input you apply all sorts
of different calculations to it
technically those or guide based
calculations you do an end guide you
take two qubits do something that you
get a result but essentially you have an
input you calculate something and even
an output and use basically you can
calculate every everything you want to
calculate with these Universal quantum
computers while quantum computers like
device can really only solve
optimization problems but actually as it
turns out both approaches can be used to
solve the factorization problem and we
are short algorithm from 1994 which uses
guides to solve this problem and in
quantum annealing we have various
approaches since 2002 and one its plot
that was a little bit in the next couple
of slides as well how they work to
actually solve the factoring problem as
an optimization problem so let's dive a
little bit into quantum computing and
what I need to understand to to explore
a little bit Shor's algorithm and really
with the idea of giving you an
understanding of how can someone derive
an algorithm that gives me now such a
dramatic improvement
and classical algorithm which takes
exponential time to solve so the basic
building blocks for quantum computers
I would recall cubits cubits is the
equivalent of a classical bit a
classical bit is either 0 or 1 a qubit
is now a you can almost think of it as a
quantum mechanical system which can be
in any state you want it to be and you
don't actually really know what size it
is but once you measure this quantum
mechanical system it is either going to
be 0 or 1 and this is an this is
something that we're going to explore it
later on that while before we measure
this system we don't know which size it
is but it can be actually in a
superposition it can be in a state where
all of these qubits can interact with
each other and only at the very end of
my processing step I will measure the
system and all of those superposition
side will apply to be terminate and I
know it's either 0 or 1 but it's really
a quantum mechanical system you don't
really know what it is it's neither 0
it's neither 1 it is something in
between quite often we then assign
variables to it and here you can see a
representation of one of those qubits we
have this two basis 0 and 1 which
basically represent this 0 means if I
measure this particular qubit in 100% of
the cases I will get the the measurement
outcome of 0 the 1 means in 100% of the
case of measurement it will give me the
measurement outcome of one and our qubit
is in this superposition of those two
with alpha and beta those are two
complex numbers I can represent those
and that can now define the side of this
particular qubit now we call alpha and
beta probability amplitudes because if I
measure this particular I'm a qubit I
will now get the probability of the
measurement outcome for to get the
measurement outcomes 0 the probability
is going to be alpha squared and the
probability of getting the measurement
outcome of one it's going to be beta
squared remember when I measure this
part
even though I have two complex numbers
associated with it when I measure it
it's going to be either zero or one with
a certain probability associated with it
and the probabilities are really defined
by those two numbers in pricing Li to
the squared for alpha and beta you know
I know it's going to end up in zero and
with those two numbers I can represent
those qubits it's basically a
mathematical representation of the
quantum mechanical system that the
quantum computer is operating but
remember all of these measurements and
everything we do in the quantum world is
probabilistic everything is just a
probability I can put I quantum in a
state where I can tell you in exactly
half of my measurement it's going to be
zero and half of my measurement is going
to be one which is perfect for random
numbers for example because I can tell
you hi you don't really know whether
it's zero one it's exactly equal
probability of getting zero and one so
just take one cubed measure at five
trillion times and I get five trillion
random bits but obviously I don't really
know whether I get zero one it's all
defined by probabilities which has a big
implication on the algorithms because
the Agron's will also only give me
probabilities there's no algorithm that
can give me I run through this algorithm
once and it will give me the answer yes
it is this answer it will always only
give me yeah I think three percent
probability is gonna be this answer for
example so quite often you run these
algorithms natural times to really see
where you end up with the second
principle that we need for Shor's
algorithm is the concept of entanglement
and that gets slightly philosophical I
want to focus a little more on the
mathematical part of this and hangman is
basically a property where I can have
two qubits and I know that there's some
correlation between those two qubits in
a classical world have two bits and the
two bits are completely independent of
each other neither of those those bits
will interact with the other and if I if
this cube if this bit is one doesn't
matter what this is in a quantum world I
can have a relationship I correlation
between those those two qubits and a
simple example is this passed out of two
qubits so this state is here a style
where you can set wave to cubits in
those funny notations the first zero is
the value of the first qubit the second
zero is the value of the second qubit
but if I would measure this qubit here
and let's suppose I measure the first
qubit as being zero it cannot be the
second one because you know the first
year the first qubit was zero so the
second qubit has to be zero as well I
know that the second qubit is going to
be zero
simply because I measure the first qubit
and there's no way because I don't have
zero ones or one zero in there that the
second qubit could something different
than zero so I take basically two qubits
give them into this quantum mechanical
system prepare this best diet and now I
have two qubits there are separated from
each other but in this quantum
mechanical system those qubits are now
correlated or what we call entangled and
now I could give one qubit to Ellis and
send her to the moon and one qubit to
Bob and send him to Mars and I know that
if Ellis looked at her qubit and Ellis
says oh I got zero I now bob has a zero
as well even now there is no
communication in between now simply
because there is correlation those
properties now I need obviously those
two qubits I need to prepare them
together and then I can send them
anywhere I want and they are correlated
without any communication in between
those two there's lots of philosophical
implications because I could give I
could put those two qubits light-years
away from each other and did I really
find a way of communicating faster than
life
now I didn't because if Ellie's measures
it's going to be zero if she wants to
tell Bob hi I'm at zero
she needs to communicate this
information to Bob which obviously she
needs a few light years to do so but
it's an important principle that we're
going to use in Shor's algorithm as well
in the mind thing for you to understand
is the exponential large size I can look
into when dealing with those quantum
systems let's suppose I take two
classical bits I can represent four
possible states with two classical bits
but only one of them at the time so
you know if I mean you see the foresight
there my system with those two bits is
in one of those sites at any one point
at any point in time in a quantum world
I can take two qubits and basically at
the end when I measure this system it's
also gonna be in one of those four
states but before I measure this system
the because of superposition those
qubits came in all four states at the
same time and only when I measure the
system the system will collapse one of
those four sites and this is exactly now
a situation we're gonna exploit the wave
have n qubits I can represent two to the
power of n states while I do
calculations I still at the end of the
day need to know what the result is of
my calculation so I need to measure at
some stage and then it will collapse
obviously to those n styles but you're
in calculation I have two to the power
of n States which is a massive amount of
my state that I can represent with just
a few amount of qubits so now I know if
everything kind of to look into shorts
algorithm and in how it works and we're
gonna look into this so the main idea
for that show have was actually if I
want to look into how to factor n into P
and Q into those prior to prime numbers
I don't actually need to solve that
problem that problem is equivalent to a
different problem and basically he
looked into number sequences and he
realized from number theory that you
have a number sequence for example you
look at the number sequence here and you
multiply the previous number by 2 1 2 4
8 16 32 if you now do if you now use
this number sequence and to this not 15
for example in in this example you end
up with a number sequence 1 2 5 1 2 4 8
want to fight this is what we call a
periodic sequence so it's always going
to be the same kind of sequence of 1 2 4
8 and we can now define a number which
is called the period which is 4 which is
basically then the number of the the
amount of numbers before it repeats
itself
and the underlying algorithm from sure
is that if I want to find out the
factors for this number n if I want to
find out this P and Q I can actually
transform this into the problem of
finding the period R and that turns out
for that problem I can run it very
easily on a quantum computer so
basically if I look into this and the
cool thing is and I want to show you
this on the next slide the mathematics
behind it is actually fairly trivial a
basic level of linear algebra gives
everything to understand how this works
so the only thing you need to accept is
that in out of number theory there's a
theorem which basically says this number
this function f fi X to the power of M
of n is a periodic function if X has
particular properties and now I only
need to find the number the period R and
with this I have my augers and Shaw
which we run through in quite some
detail actually but essentially it's
comprised of three phases first is I
turn this factoring problem into a
period finding problem and that's
actually trivial then I use a quantum
computer to actually give me this period
are to solve this period on a classic
computer is again really really hard
actually on a classic computer still of
exponential complexity which means that
this algorithm on a classic computer
does not give me any advantage
whatsoever but I can use the quantum
Fourier transform and that gives me the
speed up and then buys you won't have to
period I can really very trivially use
this to find the factor so stage one or
step one and step three are really
trivial step two is where all the magic
happens and that's where the that's
where the main speed-up comes now I
don't want to go into too much detail
but it's actually really simple so I
think you can download the slides and
you can look through this I know that FA
is periodic I know that X to the power
of 0 is 1 I mean everything to the power
of 0 is 1 and if R is not my period I
know because the function is periodic
that X to the power of our mod n equals
1/2 equals the same what it was before
because it is period
really was basically algebraic and now
use the X to the power 4 I equals x to
the power of half to the power of 2 and
I can just write it in a different form
which gives me this multiplication of
two numbers that will give 0 mod n so if
I can use this if I have this hour I
have these two numbers so but if those
two numbers mod N is an those are an
integer multiple of n because their
product is 0 mod n so that means they're
an integer the multiple of n so either
those are directly factors or if they're
not directly factors each one of those
has a factor in common with a number I
want to look at so the greatest common
divisor which is actually not too hard
to compute classically it's just an N
squared complexity so by computing the
greatest common divisor for each of
those numbers will then I have my
factors for for n and that is really
simple but to get to this R is really
really hard but I can put this together
in a really a quick example let's
suppose I have N equals 15 now everybody
can calculate it in their head that the
prime numbers are 3 & 5 basically I
choose any integer between 1 and 15 and
let's really use for the sake of
simplicity let's use x equals 2 so you
can see my period mod 15 is 1 2 4 I it
so I have a period 4 I can see this
that's a really hard part to calculate
but with the period for the greatest
common divisor of X to the power of our
half as our as 4 so our half is 2 X is 2
so that's 2 to the power of 2 which is 4
so the greatest common divisor of 3 and
15 and 5 and 15 so so 4 minus 1 and 4
plus 1 is obviously 3 and 5 and when you
calculate this true actually in every
case you come up with 3 and 5 so that's
exactly what Shaw's algorithm is all
about but the really hard part is
figuring out
what is this period our and this is kind
of where the quantum computer quantum
algorithm comes in and those quantum
computers or those quantum algorithms
always work in the same principle you
basically you you initialize basically
the result that you want to see and say
let's think of we want to get a 256 bit
number or 2048 bit number and you
basically every bit every bit of this
bit representation is going to be either
0 I want so you basically put this in an
equal superposition so every bits you
basically put that 50% 0 on 50% 1
because they don't really know what it
is so it's really kind of like at 50%
then you run through this quantum
Fourier transform which will use
amplitude amplification so with every
iteration of this algorithm
those amplitudes will now go towards 1
or 2 0 which is going to be the final
result and you run this through a number
of times and then you measured at the
end and you will see when you end up
with I gonna have an example of this
when we run this through on a real
quantum computer but just to summarize
Shor's algorithm all together is a
fairly simple you choose any random
number I which is smaller than n you
compute the greatest common divisor if
this is not one actually you found you
found a fact and you're done but that's
obviously not most likely not the case I
use my quantum computer to find this
period are and once I have our I just
need to find the greatest common divisor
of those two two terms and I'm done so
another example I choose randomly number
seven calculi appeared R equals four
if this brides come divisor for D idn't
15 and 50 and 15 gives me three and five
so it all works fine I can now use this
and use a library a toolkit called kiss
kit which is an open-source toolkit
there's now at least five or six
different open-source platforms how you
can use quantum computers and how you
can program quantum computers either on
quantum simulators or on real quantum
hardware and I gave you some Ref
see you can look up those it's actually
kind of fairly easy to go through but
they all saw the same and here you see
an example of this amplitude
amplification basically in the end you
see all of the possibilities what the my
prime numbers could be they're all in
the same probability what they could be
that's my starting point and once I run
through this algorithm and I ran through
this Shaw's algorithm on from these
references the amplitude of the correct
results have now been amplified and the
amplitude of the wrong results have now
been kind of like gone down to zero and
I actually see that there's two results
are equal to 0 and I equals 4
I equals 0 is obviously true I'm a
probability so I discard this and I end
up with our equals 4 so this was an hour
executed on a quantum simulator quantum
simulator I can simulate a condo site on
my normal computer but remember in
quantum computing exploiting this fact
that at this massive large space of 2 to
the power of n so I'm going to really
trouble simulating more than whatever
100 cubits or so on a normal computer
and but for smaller ones for
illustration it's actually quite cool so
the cool thing is iBM has a quantum
computer that you can publicly access
you can write a quantum computer program
execute it towards their cloud it's very
simple you just change how my back end
is the simulator you change the back
into IBM's quantum computer and if you
execute this against a real quantum
computer it's just a 5 cubed computer
I'm right now I still get R equals 4
with the highest probability but you see
there's lots of other probabilities and
those probabilities are representative
of all the errors you have in the system
simply because those computers that we
have right now are really pretty bad
what they are what we call noisy they
don't produce the correct result because
they're noisy they produce lots of wrong
results now by repeating my algorithm
lots of times I can still get around
this fact and obviously in this case I
still have articles for the highest
probability but obviously there has big
implications on performance because I
need to now repeat these
agoura since much more and obviously I
will end up in death cases because
obviously the noise will basically
reduce the speed up in the quantum
effect to zero and it basically
collapses to a classical computation
that I have but the cool thing is
actually with a kiss kit as well there
is a libraries for every quantum
algorithm that you know that people know
and they kind of provide easy libraries
if you wanna run Shor's algorithm to
factor Prime now to factor any numbers
you just import Shor's algorithm from
Kiske aqua which is which is library you
just say alright I want to factor this
number N equals 15 I use a simulator I
do this 1,000 times and if I run this
instance and I get a result
how cool is that you can run this
against against the quantum computer and
the only thing you need to do in this
examples if you run this against a real
quantum computer is to change this back
end from the simulator to a different
back end and now there's a call out to
IBM's quantum computer to run this on
the back end it's actually really really
cool and this feeling when you run a
quantum computing software for the first
time it's actually it's actually quite
cool so I encourage everybody to look at
kiss kit or there is quantum computing
libraries and to play around with this
so the problem obviously is and you
guessed it that in order to do anything
meaningful I need a lot of qubits so in
order to use Shor's algorithm to break
RSA 2048 I need four thousand cubits and
I need four thousand proper qubits
meaning without any noise I need for the
time of the computation there can't be
any noise on the computation as well and
it's not really surprised because when
Shaw came up with this in 1984 there
were no quantum computers he didn't have
to worry about hey can i really
implement my algorithm or not he really
just came up with a system and method so
it was never really meant to run on a
quantum computer and right now lots of
people look at Shaw's Idris and then see
all right kind of right now we have 70
qubit so it's every the qubit count
doubles every year whatever so it's
gonna be another 10 years bf before we
have Shor's algorithm
nobody's gonna run short algorithm
because it was just a theory so let's
look at some of the the researchers
where people took people took shots
algorithm and modify them and optimize
them to run on real quantum quantum
hardware so the first one was Fowler in
2012 basically the first process really
kind of I need to tweak this algorithm
so it can be so it can sustain errors
because Shaw's argument really was an
assumption there's no errors all the
qubits are fantastic no errors so
basically they used what's called the
surface codes to allow for errors to
occur and the error rate is 0.1 per side
of the of the guide error right and
Fowler came up I can run Shor's
algorithm and I can factor 2048 bit
number but I need one billion cubits to
do so which is obviously a massive
amount in terms of over eight to run
this so that was in 2012 not too long
not too long ago in any 2017 with
further optimizations from a Garmin we
suddenly kind of like a head at an
algorithm where we reduces 1 billion
cubits to just 230 million cubits in
2017 and those are really optimization
the physical connectivity of those
qubits and then George you kind of
reduces further 270 million cubits so
you can see there's a Grif make
improvements without any hard
improvements obviously that's happening
at the same time as well but obviously I
get down from 1 billion cubits to right
now 170 million cubits and the biggest
contribution was from Gidney and Akira
from Google and University in Stockholm
where they provided paper just not long
ago earlier this year where they looked
into how they could do the same thing
what everybody else is doing with just
20 million cubits now we went for in
2012 from 1 billion cubits to 2019 to 20
million cubits and we are far from the
end of the research there in terms of
optimization to this problem now I won't
go into too much detail of this of what
they do but basically they also look at
the lots of option
Asian of how things work and they're
basically also choose similar to Shaw
not really look into factoring the
numbers directly so they basically
convert this factoring problem too short
discrete algorithm problem and they have
a part that is computing computer
classically and a part that is computed
quantumly on a quantum computer and they
can show that in order to find P and Q
they can come up with obviously they
know what n is which is the
multiplication of those two they can
come up with a number whether now the
addition of those numbers are these or T
is known so if two two equations for two
variables which they can fairly easily
solve fairly easy service an
overstatement because I still need 20
million cubits to do so but obviously
the the reduction from 1 billion cubits
to 20 million cubits is massive and I
expect in the next couple of years it's
going to be lots of optimization to
shows algorithm and especially to Gideon
Akira's algorithm where this is gonna be
reduced further on obviously 20 million
cubits is still a long way away from
quantum computers that are accessible
today where we are in the realm of you
know slowly below 100 cubits at this
point in time so I wanna spend the next
you know or the last 10 minutes of my
presentation on a Protestant quantum
annealing loss is that second type of
quantum computer and that is actually
what's quite surprising to me even
though everybody's talking about sure
and the implication or cryptic
cryptography actually quantum annealing
right now is much much further ahead in
terms of solving this factorization
problem and we're gonna look into a
little bit how these algorithms work so
it's mentioned before quantum annealing
those computers are really computers can
solve an optimization problem I need to
I need to define my problem as an
optimization problem and then basically
quantum annealing computer can take this
problem and find the minimum of this
problem because it represents a physical
side and another physical side will
always end up in the ground side and I
can read them this ground
that and a half day solution to my
problem and there's really a cool cool
theorem where you want to find you want
to go into the lowest point you want to
find this lowest point on the right hand
side so how do we end up in this lowest
point and not get caught up in those
minimas in between and there's lots of
ways how you can do this from the from
the physical system and that's a really
cool case on this quantum annealing case
where there is a theorem that says if I
start in a really in a very easy quantum
mechanical system in is really easy
quantum mechanical system I know the
ground state so this is my problem I
want to solve is Here I am starting here
and I really know where I am I can now
slowly evolve an adiabatic means slowly
evolving this decide from this here to
this type I really want to be and now
this theorem gives me a guarantee or
physical proof that I will end up in the
maximum on an optimal minima of the
problem I want to solve and it's really
cool so I have Hamiltonians are
functions that define a physical system
but basically if you look at the first
function if you put in s equals 0 you
end up in this height 0 which is my easy
to understand system where I know the
local minima and in my calculation I
slowly move s from 0 to 1 and if I made
one I'm in a stage Heights 1 which is
the problem that I really want to solve
but this adiabatic theorem guarantees to
me that I will end up in the maximum
minima for the problem and I really want
to solve which is really really cool
because it gives me I'm I know I'm not
gonna be caught into some local minima
but still essentially I want to solve an
optimization problem how do I do this
and the first research came from Burgess
in 2002 from a Microsoft where you know
he provided a foundation of hi I want to
solve basically if I want to look into
the problem n equals P times Q I'm
looking for P and Q so that this
equation is true so I'll just need to
solve this I need to write this as an
optimization problem and basically we
rewrote this as n minus P Q square
and this is a positive function this is
always great to zero and this is
obviously only zero if N equals P Q and
if you write it this way you have what's
called a cube or a quadratic
unconstraint binary optimization problem
which you can happily run on any quantum
annealer that is out there and you
basically use binary representation it's
really just a fancy way up here of
writing P I and Qi are just the eyes you
know bit it's either 0 or 1 and you
basically now write this down and it's a
very simple example my example 15 is 5
times 3 now I'm in binary notation P
equals x11 the last bit always has to be
1 because the prime number can't be an
even number and not just you know n
minus P Q squared I just write this
through and kind of by hand and see how
this is function e to minimise now and I
can run this against T waves quantum
computer and if I find the minimum I
know and equals P Q because that's by
definition a positive function so I can
use Quantum's matías con computer they
provide a library as well and you see
the link here you can download it it's
basically the same thing I just call
factor P P is my product and I can run
this on this device quantum computer the
problem is if I just use this without
any optimization I need N squared cubed
for this so I mean my number of qubits
that I need really kind of like grow
quite heavily and for larger numbers
there is not sustainable I had to do but
I wanted to show you it's all
probabilistic so if I run this one time
I end up with my for 15 for the P and Q
for my two prime numbers is 1 and 7
which is obviously wrong
so I ran this once and I didn't really
end up in the in the right spot but it
around is 5 times
now I've already have 5 and 3 is already
60% i'm you know probabilities and if i
ran this 50 times you know I know my
prime numbers are 3 and 5 so I know I
need to run those quantum algorithms
more and more often to make sure I end
up in the same results I'm gonna skip
over some of those
because virtually all optimizations of
now this base you know of purchases work
where he pays he looked into hey my
multiplication matrix that you write out
as a function to be minimized there can
be lots of optimizations virtually all
of the work that I will present him now
is based on optimizations of how you do
the multiplications down below here if
you've ever done multiplications by hand
you know you start on the right and you
kind of multiply the lowest numbers
endianness carryovers to the left and
virtually all of those optimizations go
through this how I can do these
multiplications much easier 3d and
Agassi did some work in 2006 16 where I
use some of these optimizations to
remove some of the order of the degrees
so they were already able to factor a
number greater than 200 thousands with
almost nine hundred qubits now divides
qubits on quantum annealing I notice
don't have to be as good as universal
quantum computer qubits so D wife
announces system with I think around
five thousand cubits for next year so
nine hundred qubits what was was what
available then then Pegman on universal
quantum computers the biggest prime
number is less than 100 and I these guys
in 2016 could already no affect the
number that I was over 200,000 the big
breakthrough was from John yet and in
Indiana in April two thousand eighteen
and it's really kind of mind-blowing you
see the next one which was really just
two months after really round
optimization of this multiplication map
and I've now raised they could factor a
number which is greater than 350,000
with just 94 qubits remember TF comes up
with 5000 qubit quantum computer next
week next year and it's all based on
this optimization problem that we solve
for factoring and with the optimization
to the multiplication table and then
paying in 2000 in earlier this year
really and you can see this submission
was received in July while the previous
submission was I think
and I presume release just months after
optimizers even further and they've been
able to affect a number that is right of
1 million with just 90 cubed so that's
already 20 bit number so right now when
you look into the problem of hey can I
use a quantum computer to affect our
prime numbers
Universal quantum computers and Shores
algorithms are now where compared to
quantum annealer and which contain
Manila's I can already do this with 20
bit 20 bit numbers so there's three
things really interesting so they they
could run this on an already existing
hardware today and all of those
algorithms and that's a really big
takeaway that you have to do this I
don't have just one quantum problem
there on itself it's always a hybrid
model of some classical computation in
some quantum computation I really use a
classic computer what he's good at
and a quantum computer what are quantum
computers it's good so my point is
quantum annealer are a thousandfold
better right now than Shor's algorithm
on universal quantum computers but
because they are too noisy right now we
are far away from breaking anything that
is in used in practical terms right now
the biggest numbers a 20-bit number but
obviously we we know those two kind of
like converging curves here
the algorithms are getting better and
better at the same time the quantum
hardware gives me more and more qubits
as well so both of them will actually
have a big impact
I can't just rely on my prediction
saying hi the number of qubits grow by
50% every year so I'm going to be fine
for the next 50 years you're neglecting
the improvements that the algorithms
will make over the next of next couple
of years so - so a couple of myths and
reality sure nobody's going to implement
show on any quantum computer whatsoever
Shaw was a theoretical work there are
practical work you know the relations of
this work that will be implemented at
some point obviously on the on the basis
of source algorithms
people will break the RSA encryption it
is a matter of time now we can argue
whether
it's ten years 20 years 50 years but
we're only arguing about the time we're
not arguing arguing about that it will
happen and obviously there's lots of
cases where this is already as an impact
right now if I have bitcoins right now
and if my public key is known I don't
care whether it takes me 20 years to get
the private key to those two those
bitcoins forgetting 20 years there's you
know one and a half million bitcoins
from Satoshi flying around which is
around 12 billion dollars right now hey
if someone comes to me in San Andreas
you know can you can you build me
quantum community is really hard it
takes me 12 billion dollars you know hey
yes - dollars right there so I'm so
anyway it takes it will be quite a while
but I want to provide an overview of the
aggro algorithms I started this talk
talking about high trust the isometric
world of the RSI world but there's
plenty of work and this is a kind of you
know from this Chinese paper in the very
very end that's the that's their the end
statement there's plenty of work
underway right now to use quantum
annealer also to look into symmetric
encryption so if you say hi I just use
symmetric encryption I find that might
not be holding up for too long and I
thank you very much amount of time thank
you very much for your time
good for questions
we don't have time for questions you can
find me anywhere if you have some
questions happy to engage with you
thanks so much